tiens à ne devrait pas tarder à lui
bon alors est ce que stéphane est déjà
en ligne
un salut and la nuit se passe bien
paranal oui oui la nuit est claire sans
turbulence propice aux mesures et toi
comment ça va ça va bien on observe
l'opérateur de services vient de lancer
notre projet tu as vu orion est déjà
bien aux 1500 les lumières les photos
qui nous parviennent maintenant été émis
par ces étoiles quand nous étions à la
fin de l'empiré romain oui et à côté la
constellation du taureau quatre cent
cinquante années lumière en europe la
renaissance galilée et kepler et ses
lois universelles sans compter que l'on
perçoit si peu de l'univers avec notre
oeil
juste la partie optique du spectre
électromagnétique entre le violet à 0,4
micromètres et l'infrarouge à 0 1
micromètre nos sens nous trompent le
soleil notre étoile avec sa température
de 6000 quelle ville rayonne
principalement dans le visible mais
l'essentiel de l'univers est beaucoup
plus froid il rayonne à des longueurs
d'onde beaucoup plus grande wim dans les
nébuleuses du taureau ou dorion où se
forment les étoiles
les étoiles naissent dans des nuages de
gaz de poussières ou la lumière visible
ne pénètre pas un milieu vraiment très
froid de l'ordre de 20 kelvin et comme
il est froid ce milieu rayonne dans le
domaine millimétriques et infrarouges
lointains
et c'est pour étudier ce milieu froid
que l'on construit toutes ces grandes
antennes qui observent le ciel comme
alma par contre avec le very large
telescope interferometer le vlt y à
paranal on observe en infrarouge proche
une gamme de longueurs d'onde qui permet
de vous l'environnement très proche des
étoiles et les étoiles elle même
ces longueurs d'onde correspondent à des
températures de 1000 à 3000 kelvin avec
le vlt y on voit bien les poussières
chaude proche des jeunes étoiles en
formation ces poussières qui forment les
briques élémentaires des planètes elle
absorbe la lumière visible et
ultraviolette de l'étoile pour l'art et
mettra plus grandes longueurs d'onde
dans l'infrarouge et si elles sont plus
loin dans le millimétriques parce
qu'elles sont plus froides
ces grains de poussière sont mélangés au
gaz et forme une galette aplati qui
tourne autour de l'étoile jeunes comme
la terre autour du soleil en suivant les
lois de kepler on appelle cette galette
un disque protoplanétaire si sa masse
est suffisante il peut former des
planètes
loin dans le disque les poussières sont
plus froides et met à des longueurs
d'onde plus grande par exemple à 150
unités astronomiques de l'étoile ou bien
150 fois la distance de la terre au
soleil le disque est vraiment très froid
oui 20 galine
tellement froid que les poussières sont
couverts d'une couche de glace composé
de molécules comme le monoxyde de
carbone et l'eau il n'y a que la couche
supérieure du disque qui est encore
éclairé par les toiles comme dans cette
image optique 2 h h30 obtenu grâce au
télescope spatial hubble
le disque est vue par la tranche et les
poussières dans le plan du disque
absorbe toute la lumière et on ne voit
pas les toiles oui en optique le disque
est sombre mais à la surface les petites
poussières diffuse la lumière de
l'étoile c'est comme lorsque le
brouillard n'est pas trop épais et qu'on
discutait encore halo autour des feux
des voitures que l'on croise mais quand
on observe à 1 mm de longueur d'onde on
voit les missions des grosses poussière
qui ont absorbé la lumière de l'étoile
et la rainette à plus grandes longueurs
d'onde en millimétriques sur le plan du
disque quelques fautes on sortait encore
le milieu est très froid mais il n'est
pas complètement opaque contrairement
longueur d'onde optique au fait
qu'est-ce que tu observes en ce moment
tu le sais bien comme toi jéjé tôt oui
un objet diablement intéressant mais qui
illustre bien la complémentarité des
observations millimétriques avec les
observations aux infrarouges et optique
gg taux est une belle étoile jeunes deux
types théorie comme le soleil quand il
n'avait qu'un million d'années mais là
il s'agit d'un système triple et pot
massif environ 1,3 fois la masse du
soleil répartis entre les trois étoiles
le système est composé d'une étoile
simple la plus massive aa et d'un
système binaire à b composé des étoiles
à b1 et la b2 à b1 et la b2 sont séparés
par cinq unités astronomiques et tourne
autour de leur centre de masse en
environ 15 ans au contraire à et ab sont
séparés de 35 unités astronomiques et
leur période est donc beaucoup plus
longue environ 500 ans on appelle ce
type de système où les trois étoiles
sont gravitationnellement lier un
système hiérarchique triple en fait il
s'agit même d'un système quintuple car
au sud à environ 10 secondes d'arc soit
1500 unités astronomiques
il y a une autre étoile double gg tomber
c'est grâce aux observations infrarouge
proche effectuées à l'observatoire de
paranal avec le vlt y que l'on a trouvé
que l'étoile gg tôt à béthune étoiles
binaires en millimétriques on ne voit
pas les étoiles théorie elle rayonne
bien trop peu mais revenons ag jeetoo
son environnement composé de gaz et de
poussières et complexe oui lien bel
anneau de matières qui s'étend entre 180
et 260 unités astronomiques
puis un disque plus ténue jusqu'à
environ 800 unités astronomiques
voilà un bel exemple de complémentarité
entre observation millimétriques
infrarouge et optiques
en millimétriques en images la poussière
froide composé de grains déjà assez gros
environ 1 mm en taille tandis qu'avec un
télescope optique infrarouge proche on
observe comme pour h h30 les petites
poussières à la surface de l'anneau mais
ici les étoiles restent visibles car le
système est presque vu de face en
infrarouge tu ne voient que la surface
du disque alors quand millimétriques le
milieu et transparent on peut compter
les grains de poussière et estives et la
masse totale de l'anneau enfin cela
suppose que tu connais bien la nature
des poussières observé il reste encore
quelques incertitudes
non oui on fait du mieux qu'on peut
ceci dit comme l'anneau et froid en
millimétriques je peux aussi mesurer la
température des poussières grâce à des
images à plusieurs longueurs d'onde pour
cela il faut ajuster un modèle aux
observations à toutes les observations
millimétriques de façon à déterminer les
paramètres physiques les plus probables
de toute façon l'essentiel de la masser
dans le gaz la molécule de dihydrogène
h2 dont tu dois bien supposer un facteur
de proportionnalité entre quantité de
gaz et de poussière si tu veux la masse
totale de l'anneau or quel rabat-joie
bon bien sûr tu as raison mais tu sais
bien que c'est un travail de fourmi et
que la connaissance avance pas à pas oui
un travail de fourmi mais on a fait
tellement de progrès depuis la
découverte des étoiles des tories en
grâce à l'observation de ces eaux la
molécule de monoxyde de carbone qui
rayonne en millimétriques on peut
déterminer le mouvement du gaz dans
l'anneau externe on a pu ainsi vérifier
que cette annonce suit les lois de
kepler il tourne autour de son système
stellaire triple comme les planètes
autour du soleil en mesurant la vitesse
de rotation du disque on détermine la
masse totale des trois étoiles 1,3
masses solaires la masse totale des
étoiles centrale déduite de la rotation
delanoë les masses des étoiles déduites
et des observations optiques sont
maintenant cohérente
ces étoiles ne sont pas très massives 06
masses solaires pour en a 0,4 pour ab
1,03 pour ab 2 elles sont
caractéristiques de la plupart des
étoiles de la galaxie
notre étoile le soleil est un peu plus
massif que la moyenne d'ailleurs en
observant régulièrement dans le temps
avec le vlt la binaire ab on va même
être capable de contraindre son orbite
son inclinaison et donc de raffiner la
mesure de leur masse et pour cela il va
nous falloir encore une bonne dizaine
d'années en plus du grand anneau de gaz
et de poussière il y a aussi un disque
circulaire autour de 1
et des images venant d'allemagne montre
qu'il est assez grand et massif pour
former une planète comme jupiter
la partie centrale chaude de ce disque
est aussi vu en infrarouge mais en
infrarouge en détecte aussi de tout
petits disques show autour de à b1 et la
b2 que vous vous ne pouvez pas voir un
mini métriques ils sont trop petits
comme les deux étoiles sont très proches
l'une de l'autre le gaz et la poussière
ne peuvent rester sur des orbites stable
que très près de chaque étoile à une ou
deux unités astronomiques tout au plus
au delà il ya une zone instable où la
matière ne fait que transiter avant de
tomber sur l'un ou l'autre de ces petits
disques la gravitation sculpte ses
systèmes de même de m oui et le rayon
interne delanoë tronqué par effets de
marées dues aux étoiles central de la
même façon le disque de aaa est plus
grand que ceux de à b1 et la b2 karaha
et ab sont dix fois plus éloignée que à
b1 et la b2 et le disque de haras
rayonne sur tout en longueur d'onde
millimétriques
car il est plus loin de son étoile et
donc plus froid de plus les étoiles
continuent à grandir en nacre et en la
matière présente dans leur environnement
proche c'est vrai un disque comme celui
de a aurait dû disparaître il ya très
longtemps sans apport de matière
extérieure elle provient de bras de
matières qui transitent depuis l'anneau
externe dans la cavité la zone
gravitationnellement instable en tombant
sur les étoiles et leur disque circulent
stellaire
les observations du monoxyde de carbone
obtenus avec alma le montre bien la
cavité n'est pas entièrement vide cela
permet de nourrir le disque de haras qui
garde une masse suffisante pour former
d'éventuels planète
quand on pense que 50% des étoiles se
forment dans des systèmes stellaires
multiples ont réalisé quel formidable
réservoir de planète il représente et
ses planètes peuvent aussi bien se
former dans les anneaux externe que dans
les disques internes comme celui de
l'oat à la réalité est complexe et seuls
les observations à plusieurs longueurs
d'onde nous permettront de comprendre
comment former les systèmes stellaires
et leur cortège planétaire
pour le thé retour de victhom tu as
raison retournant faire toute la lumière
sur ses mystères bonne nuit travail ou
bien